if there was one way to describe
Andromeda it would be average it's no
secret that the game was released to
mixed reception most of it coming from
numerous bugs and questionable facial
animations some of that is still present
but for the most part it seems alright
although I can't be entirely certain if
anything has actually changed because
like probably many of you I've never
actually played Andromeda the reviews
were enough to turn me off the game for
good and I never had any reason to
download it until today having now
played Andromeda twice I can say that
while its mixed reception is warranted
there are some rather interesting parts
to this game that I found quite
enjoyable and I'd even go as far as to
say that they're the best iterations of
it in the series but enough beating
around the bush we really need to dive
into this thing to understand why so
without further Ado let's get started so
Mass Effect Andromeda takes place 600
years after the original trilogy but
many of the events that led to this
start within the trilogy in 2185 or
around the time of Mass Effect 2 a
project called the Andromeda initiative
was launched with the sole purpose of
making a one-way trip to the engine
Andromeda galaxy the nearest galaxy to
the Milky Way leaving the charge was
billionaire Visionary Gian Garson she's
the figurehead for most of the marketing
material so it was her job to give
people to join the reason why we haven't
heard any of this despite the fact that
it happened during the trilogy is likely
due to the game's development Mass
Effect was always envisioned to be a
Trilogy so the writers had a plan as to
when and what would be revealed the idea
about Andromeda in the initiative was
likely something they thought of after
the release of the trilogy so it would
have been impossible for them to plan
that far ahead as for why G and Garson
decided to start this Expedition
but we don't really know why okay that's
a lie there is a reason but it's a
secret for now which is a problem we'll
discuss this more at the end of the
video where you'll likely hear more
about this reasoning for yourself in
game but the fact that we aren't given
an actual reason is a bit odd until that
secret is revealed the player is told
that the initiative started to Simply
explore Andromeda it's not a terrible
reason to leave the Galaxy it's just not
really a great hook for a story but like
I said we'll come back to this at the
end of the video to get to Andromeda a
lot needed to be planned out in advance
first was actually making sure Andromeda
was even able to be colonized many teams
were dedicated to finding so-called
golden worlds where the races of the
Galaxy could live these teams reported
that there was a surplus of these worlds
which meant that Andromeda was a good
place to go afterwards that we need to
figure out how to actually fly there the
Milky Way and Andromeda aren't touching
one another so they would need to travel
through dark space for an unknown amount
of time the main Hub of the fleet was a
ship called the Nexus which would act as
an alternative Citadel once they arrived
on the ship were various different races
and just about all the Krogan I
mentioned the races specifically because
following the Nexus were four arcs each
one was tailor-made for a specific race
the human solarian turian and asari arcs
there is a fifth Arc but according to
the lore it hasn't launched yet so it'll
be some time before they arrive on the
ship are all the other races in the game
like the hanar drill quarians El core
volis Etc basically this is an in-game
reason why a large portion of the game's
races are missing once the arcs in the
Nexus arrived a new group of people
called Pathfinders were dedicated to
setting up outposts and exploring the
new planets the human Pathfinder was a
man named Alec Ryder who just so happens
to be the father of our main character
Scott Ryder unlike the original trilogy
though both genders of Ryder are Canon
Scott and Sarah Ryder are twins and are
both in the game the only difference
being who is the twin so for example you
can visit Sarah as Scott on the Human
Arc but if you're Sarah then you visit
Scott on the ark basically one of the
siblings takes the role of the main
character the other becomes a side
character depending on who you pick
obviously this is a huge change for this
series as this is the first time the
protagonist is in Commander Shepard
given the events of the trilogy it makes
sense why they aren't present in this
game but it's still a major change one
that immediately split people's opinions
personally I like Ryder I think he's a
solid protagonist but that's mostly
because he's a blank slate I can't
really say whether I like Ryder or
Shepard more since they're supposed to
be vessels for the player so saying I
dislike Commander Shepard would kind of
just be insulting myself that being said
though it is strange to play a Mass
Effect game without Shepard and the crew
which is something I knew I would need
to get over soon if I was even going to
remotely enjoy this game once Ryder gets
out of cryo and gets checked out by the
ship's doctor we're introduced to the
new dialogue system it's still the same
dialogue wheel as the rest of the
trilogy but the Paragon and Renegade
morality systems are completely gone
this was inevitable given how little
importance the system seemed to get over
the years and it was only a matter of
time until it was gone for good
replacing it though are tone indicators
in the middle of the wheel there is a
symbol that represents the kind of tone
you want to convey whether that be
emotional casual logical or professional
there are also other icons for responses
that are questions flirting or ones that
Advance the plot this is a major
improvement over the original and my
personal favorite as it goes back to our
early discussions regarding how people
would pick options simply because it was
Paragon or Renegade and not because they
actually wanted to choose that option
I know not everyone does that all the
time but I can think of numerous
occasions where I was conflicted on what
to say so I just went with the one that
fits my character's alignment at that
time Andromeda gives you the chance to
choose what you want to say without
being weighed down by some arbitrary
scoring system that dictated your
morality as such though things like
speech checks are non-existent in this
game but because there's no binary good
and evil approach most of the decisions
we make are in the gray furthermore that
also means we won't be discussing things
like Renegade options in this video
since those don't exist the game still
has choices that we will be discussing
just not in the same way that we've been
discussing them so far in the series
it's been roughly I don't know long
enough since we've had something go
wrong so let's add that to the mix upon
entering the Galaxy the ark hit
something strange this mass of thorns
and tendrils is called The Scourge this
sadly doesn't really play a major role
in the overall story but it is something
we will periodically bring up like right
now as it's currently causing Mass
damage to the ship despite the damage
everyone is okay except Sarah whose
cryopod was damaged I'll be honest I
thought she was going to die here I
could have assumed that she wouldn't
since you're able to customize both the
twins before starting the game but I've
also played Fallout 4 and had my wife
whom I spend hours creating get killed
in 20 minutes so nothing was off the
table for me thankfully she lives but
she'll be unconscious for quite a while
this means of her short one on our team
though as the Pathfinder doesn't work
alone so Scott gets to team up with his
Dad and explore the planet they call
Habitat 7. writer in the company then
meets and get a look at habitat 7 and
it's less than ideal the skins of those
people made back then were outdated
since the trip alone took 600 years so
the planets have changed the teams that
form up and take shuttles to the planet
and hopes of seeing what this world is
really about on the way though some of
the shuttles including our own are hit
by The Scourge and some of the lightning
from the planet which means we'll have
to crash land this Crash Landing alerted
some of the locals and thus begins one
of the most important parts of this
Mission first contact with other aliens
this is completely on the player to do
so no cutscenes or QuickTime events it's
all on the player to walk forward or
stay still sadly it doesn't matter since
these aliens will shoot you after enough
time anyway but I was wrapped up in the
idea that first Contact was extremely
important and that shooting should not
be the first thing we do in all honesty
I was quite nervous to move forward
since I didn't want to anger these new
aliens we met BioWare did a pretty damn
good job at adding the suspense that
comes from an interaction such as this
these alien creatures are beings called
cat they are also and this may surprise
you the main antagonist of the game
we'll have to talk about the cap more in
depth later but just know that they are
the main bad guys of Andromeda seeing as
the teams are split up and possibly
being killed by these cats we're tasked
with rendezvousing with everyone this
section of the game is where I got
shocked back into reality because one of
the location locations we can find is a
small research base and inside is a
hostile robot when we walk near it our
crewmate says kill the robots ugh the
Geth would love this that sentence like
I was some sort of Sleeper Agent
practically awoke me because I had
totally forgotten up until now that I
was playing a Mass Effect game and it
wouldn't be the last time this happened
either I think the footage alone could
explain why I think this but playing
this game is a completely different
experience since the combat is no longer
boots on the ground and so much of this
game has been altered the team behind
Andromeda did want to make a fresh new
experience and wanted to move away from
the trilogy as much as possible and they
definitely did just that but it was
still a shock regardless once everyone
comes together they determine that this
monolith on the planet is the thing
causing the severe weather since it's
releasing undirected energy which is
being put back on the planet in the form
of lightning the team then makes their
way inside the building and Alec decides
to interact with it using Sam Sam is an
AI that is very similar to Edie but the
Edie from Mass Effect 2 one that was
less self-aware the major difference is
that Sam is inside the mind of the
Pathfinders via an implant whereas Edie
was just talking via radio this is very
clearly illegal given how how many
restrictions are placed on AI already
but to be fair we aren't really in the
Milky Way anymore once Alec interacts
with the monolith the building activates
and removes the harsh weather but it
releases this Cloud that shoots the two
off the building Ryder's helmet is
cracked in the crash and needs to be
repaired and Alec decides to sacrifice
himself by giving him his helmet and
transferring Sam's control over to Ryder
so he can have these same functions as
he did Alec then passes away and Ryder
collapses but that's because the implant
was affecting his brain at least until
Sam helps him recover seeing his Alec
transferred Sam over to Ryder that means
he's the new human Pathfinder before
things continue though we get a quick
look at another cut who seems to be the
leader of sorts called the archon he
seems interested in this technology but
can't quite understand how to use it
which leads to him walking away and the
game gives us control of Ryder again as
a first mission it's pretty okay it
functions like a decent tutorial but
part of me is honestly kind of shocked
that Alec isn't the main character Alec
Rudder has so much backstory and oozes
Intrigue then I'm surprised this wasn't
given to us at the start once we become
Pathfinder one of the side missions we
get is finding these memories across the
Galaxy these then unlock various logs
and recordings from Alec allowing us to
see a different side of the rider family
we learned that Alec was a devoted and
determined man he was a former N7 who
served in the contact Wars when Humanity
first met alien life but he was then
eventually dishonorably discharged
thanks to him becoming too obsessed with
Advanced AI the reason behind this was
that his wife Ellen was dying of an
incurable disease and he couldn't allow
her to pass on that's why he created Sam
an AI tasked with curing his wife this
sadly wasn't working the council caught
on to his AI Antics he was running out
of money Elm was already willing to
accept her death and his kids barely got
to see their father since he was more
focused on keeping Ellen alive he was
out of options as though he was given an
opportunity to join the Andromeda
initiative doing so would allow Alex to
continue his AI development as they were
outside council's space but also give
him an opportunity to cryo-freeze his
wife while he searched the Galaxy for a
new cure it was the perfect plan given
the circumstances which is why he joined
the Expedition and became the human
Pathfinder it's only shocking how all of
this information isn't mentioned until
the player finds it themselves through a
side quest but hearing this kind of
makes me want to play as Alec instead or
at the very least have him present
throughout the game not killed off in
the first hour he's a desperate man on a
desperate mission to save the woman he
loves anyone would sympathize with him
but like I said none of this is
mentioned hell Ellen's existence isn't
even acknowledged until the side quest
is complete because the twins discovered
that their mom wasn't actually dead like
they were told as she's been on the ark
and cryo the whole time it's a shocking
reveal sure but I would have loved to
see this whole story play out
differently as Alec this could also
provide motivation as to why we joined
the initiative because as of right now
it's just simply to explore the game
could have honestly kept that main idea
but have Alex personal goal be something
more than just exploring because as the
twins the main idea is our personal
motivation we're just here to explore
which as stated isn't a terrible reason
to join the initiative just not exactly
a great story and I think in hindsight
Alex motivation is much more intriguing
and makes for the much better story this
could also play into the main narrative
is throughout the game it's really just
about making sure the worlds of
Andromeda are livable when we could have
possibly had decisions that affect the
progress of a cure or motivate Alec
assuming he was alive to do drastic
things like betraying the team to get a
sample of some plant that maybe
contained some sort of cure for Ellen
regardless of how this could have played
out I think having Alec die in the first
hour really ruins a key part of the
story since his whole plan is never told
to us until much later and by then it's
hard to still care about it once Ryder
wakes up the crew of The Ark make it to
the Nexus and a tier where I started to
notice a severe lack of cinematic
presentation coming from Andromeda which
is really strange as it has these same
advantages that Mass Effect 1 had in the
first game we were unfamiliar with the
Citadel and the Normandy so their
reveals were a surprise that's why Mass
Effect 3 doesn't Place much importance
on reviewing the Citadel because we
already know what it is within Andromeda
just about everything is new to us so
the team has the opportunity to take
full advantage of it but they didn't one
example is the Tempest Ryder eventually
becomes the captain of a ship called The
Tempest it's basically this game's
Normandy and both the Norman return in
Mass Effect 2 and its quick reveal in
Mass Effect 1 are leagues better than
what Andromeda has the Tempest just
kinda shows up it at least has some
music in the background which sounds
like the bare minimum but you'd be
surprised how much this isn't utilized
like for example take the reveal of the
Citadel and the Nexus
[Music]
the size of that ship the Ascension
Flagship of the Citadel Fleet well sizes
and everything why so touchy joker I'm
just saying you need Firepower too
Ryder good to see you on your feet
we're at the Nexus
it's the forward hub for the entire
Andromeda initiative the asari solarian
and turian arcs should be there too
let's hope they've had better luck
starting our approach now
it's almost as big as the Citadel back
home
next is control this is archive period
requesting docking clearance
Captain I'm only getting their automated
approach Channel not a live person well
like it or not we're here take us in
thank you
that is as Bland as it gets and that's
supposed to be the main Hub of the game
there is also the one time a decently
shot evacuation scene was shown which is
great within the bounds of Andromeda but
immediately outclassed by most of the
trilogy that's not to say though that
Andromeda goes without any sort of
cinematic direction as there are some
wonderful moments that the game takes
full advantage of whether it be the
Stellar landscape or some wonderful
character moments but Andromeda is
definitely lacking in this department
now some of you may mention that the
Nexus reveal is intentional since it's
actually shot down and that is a fair
point because when we arrive we realize
that it's not the welcoming party we
were envisioning but this could have
been further used to the game's
Advantage imagine the reveal of the
Citadel this insanely large structure
that's just brimming with life only to
find out that there is no life at all it
would immediately change the tone of the
scene and really set in that this
beautiful place we saw on the outside is
not as beautiful on the inside but due
to its Bland reveal the surprise of the
nexus's current state Falls flat once we
do make it to the Nexus though we can
talk to the leaders who are Kesh tan
kandros and Addison they're sort of like
the board of directors since the Nexus
has no governing body like the council
although the plan is to establish that
eventually there isn't much to say about
them other than the board of directors
comment besides the fact that tier and
kandros the turian is actually a cousin
of nyrene once we talk with the leaders
we learn why the Nexus is the way that
it is the Nexus like the ark ran into
the scourge which caused lots of damage
to the ship and also killed quite a few
of the higher ups the current director
of the Nexus is tan while kandros cash
in Addison still have some say in the
decisions it's ultimately tan who makes
it tan is nicknamed eight or the 8th
since he was actually the eighth in line
to be director meaning the other seven
before him also died to make matters
worse not only is the ship running out
of power and Supply seeing as it's been
floating in space for 14 months but this
shortage caused the Mutiny some people
were angered by all this and thus two
sides formed those that were against the
Nexus and its leadership rebelled and
are now known as Exiles these
individuals were forced to leave in axis
and never come back or else they'll be
shot given the fact that no outposts or
anything have been done on these planets
we can assume that they the Exiles
aren't exactly living the most lavish of
lives as if we didn't have enough
problems already we're the first Arc to
arrive despite the fact that it's been
14 months the Nexus has apparently not
gotten into contact with the other three
arcs yet since the other arcs weren't
responding the Nexus tried to take
matters into its own hands and create an
outpost on a nearby planet called EOS
but those two bases aren't responding
either so we're down three arcs filled
with tens of thousands of people each
half the Nexus has gone due to a mutiny
we haven't created a single surviving
Outpost or base of operations on any
Planet since we arrived the scourge is
causing major issues for the arcs and
the Nexus and now we have an entire race
of aliens that want to kill us we could
not be more if we tried
thankfully we have one way to solve this
Ryder recognizes a strange signal like
the one that was on habitat 7. he
determines that if the signal is related
to the alien Tech they found earlier
then that means they might be able to
find another one of these buildings and
do the same thing they did before this
would clear up all the Hazardous
environment on EOS and make it habitable
to get there though we're going to need
a ship which is where the reveal of the
Tempest comes in as well as an
introduction to the Companions and some
of the ship's crew as usual we'll hold
off on talking about them for now but
just introduce them so you have their
names we have Liam and Cora our two
human Companions and Vetra a female
turian there are more people present on
the ship that we won't take on missions
but like I said more on them later once
we land on EOS we see that the
settlement that was first established
here is abandoned and discovered that
the cat came by and killed everyone the
signal then leads the crew to some alien
structure it's similar in design but not
the one they're looking for these
smaller structures are called monoliths
what they're actually searching for is
called a vault Ryder then attempts to
touch the interface before being tackled
by an asari research her name is PB and
will eventually be our next companion
before we can talk with her though we're
interrupted by those Killer Robots we
found earlier once we deal with them she
can catch us up to speed on what she
knows according to her these robots she
calls Remnant are related to the alien
Tech we've been finding furthermore PB
is very obsessed with these Remnant
creatures and their origin so she's
determined to learn more about them
which is why she joins our team if the
similarities haven't slapped you in the
face by now then allow me to put it this
way an asari researcher who is
interested in an ancient alien race tags
along with the protagonist so that she
can learn more about them PB is
basically Liara if she was more
extroverted while Rider attempts to turn
on the other monoliths he and the group
will run across to Krogan named Drac as
you would expect he is also another
companion that will join our Squad
eventually Rider will open the vault and
head inside and while Andromeda may not
utilize its presentation to its fullest
that feeling of sheer spectacle that
comes from the Sci-Fi genre is ever
present throughout this game and there
is no better example than the
underground structures located here in
the vault it's a magnificent view that
really conveys how advanced this old
race of beings used to be after
reloading my game because the door
refused to open and dying to another
enemy stuck on a wall Rider makes it to
the bottom and his theory was correct
using the Vault activates the structure
and removes the dangerous environment
that engulfs the planet furthermore that
cloud that was present in the previous
Vault was not a fluke it is out chasing
the squad it's unclear what this is
exactly what the team assumes that it's
either the vault's way of rebooting
itself or it's designed to be a booby
trap after the vault is active a map of
some kind appears and shows some sort of
Central Point the team believes that
this could be the control center meaning
that planet houses a vault that controls
the other lesser volts thus multiple
planets can be restored at one time this
would easily help the initiative's main
goal of colonizing the Galaxy but before
we can take our findings to the Nexus we
have to make the first big choice of the
game now that EOS is habitable we can
create an outpost and since we're the
Pathfinder We could decide what kind of
outpost we want military or science the
difference between these two is honestly
negligible but one thing I was
pleasantly surprised to see was that our
companion's opinions actually have
meaning this was something I briefly
brought up in the Mass Effect 1 video
about how the Italian counselor goes
against our decision regarding the rack
night Queen no matter what we ended up
choosing our companions had consistent
opinions on the matter but the counselor
was the one that didn't he was designed
to be an antagonistic Force no matter
what we chose which never made sense to
me however Andromeda recognized this and
made sure to keep the companion's
opinions consistent here as well Vetra
for example will always pick scientific
and Cora will always choose military it
doesn't matter who's with them they will
always stick to their guns furthermore
something I didn't expect is that the
game is totally fine with having two
companions agree with one another I
initially thought that the game was
programmed to have the companions
disagree so that you'd have to make the
final choice but when I brought Liam and
PB along both agreed on a scientific
Outpost I was genuinely shocked by this
as I thought I'd have to bring this
problem up again but now I don't have to
the only issue I do have though is that
we don't get to see more of this as this
is the only decision in the game where
we can actually ask our companions for
their thoughts the rest going forward
will never give us the chance to do so
as for the outposts themselves like I
said the difference is negligible
Augustus Bradley is the leader for both
outposts and most if not all the
missions revolving around the Outpost at
least in my knowledge are the same it's
only the first choice of the game which
is fine so I wasn't exactly expecting
anything large but I do wish the actual
appearance of the base change at least
having a base built around military and
one built around science would require
different buildings and Personnel but
there doesn't seem to be a difference
here I also wish we got to see the Camp
being built it would make the choice
feel more personal to the player on its
own this is a small problem but it
really starts to stick out once you
realize that Andromeda tends to be quite
abrupt with things the best way I can
explain this is once again with an
example eventually Ryder and the other
Pathfinders will get together and drink
neither of them have had the chance to
sit down and relax so they determine
that now is a good time they also talk
about opening up some aged wine and it
seems like the group is ready to relax
until the screen goes to Black and
that's it we don't see the wine them
talking or even giving a hint of an idea
that the celebration actually occurred
in another example Drac wants to play a
Krogan game with Ryder and two other
Krogan named Cash and vorn Jack's final
line is how he's going to load the mini
flamethrowers they use in the game
before the others get here but then it
ends the cutscene is finished and the
mission is over we never see the game or
even the other Krogan and it's not like
they're non-existent because we meet
them multiple times during Drax
questline it's just so bizarre not only
on its own but also because once again
the original games did this much better
and this can be seen in just about every
single loyalty mission in Mass Effect 3
when we visit Ashley at the Memorial
Wall we get a brief scene of her and her
sister sitting next to each other or
after shooting with Garris the camera
pans out and shows the two looking off
into the distance these are admittedly
very short scenes but they add so much
to the game as there's no cut to Black
so it's not as abrupt as Andromeda makes
it and shows a genuine passage of time
from this scene alone we can assume that
Garrison Shepard had stayed there and
relaxed for a while if Andromeda had
just taken the time to show the
Pathfinders drinking or show The Outpost
being built it would have made the
scenes not stick out so much by ending
so abruptly once EOS has been
established Ryder can go back to the
Nexus and report to director tan this is
also the first time you're given a
chance to do something other than the
main quest so feel free to talk with the
crew and explore the Nexus the Nexus as
mentioned before is this game's version
of The Citadel compared to the Citadel
and Omega I think this version is my
least favorite there are many locations
to visit and it's quite small when
compared to the others so instead of
coming here to taking the sights and
explore you're likely just going to come
here to talk to a person and then leave
a few minutes later it's also not as
visually distinct as the other two and I
oftentimes found myself getting lost
since the arcs in the Nexus look eerily
similar speaking of talking with people
once you make it back to the Nexus
you'll find a group of protesters this
is in response to what decision a few
moments ago is these people are the
family members of the people we didn't
pick it's more of a hindrance than
anything but I appreciated its
conclusion as it slowly makes the Nexus
a realistic livable city rather than a
location in a game this can also be seen
in its actual inhabitants you may notice
a lack of alien races on the Nexus this
due to the other arcs being missing the
only Arc to make it to the Nexus so far
is the Hyperion and that Arc houses all
the humans which is why there is an
abundance of them here sadly though it's
not all it's cooped up to be as after
rescuing all the arcs I didn't notice
much of a difference in the nexus's
diversity or density safer the angara
mentioning the angara is actually a
perfect segue into our next main mission
that map Rider and the crew found is
showing another planet which they
believe to be the core of the network
that planet is located in the Onan
system but when the team warp drives to
the solar system they run right into the
cat Fleet the fleet then points all
their guns at the Tempest while the
archon decides to have a chat with Ryder
the archon is obsessed with this Remnant
technology and when he saw Alec Ryder
activate the vaults without any issue he
realized that he needed to find him as
we know Alec Ryder is dead so he won't
be able to meet him but Alec or not his
quest to uncover The Remnant Secrets
will be stopped this gives us albeit a
small one but a notable idea as to what
the archon is doing here it doesn't
explain who the cat are but at least we
know something about the archon once the
crew regains control of the Tempest they
speed off into the scourge and somehow
manage to make it out alive but out of
the frying pan and Into the Fire as they
say as the crew runs into yet another
alien species thankfully these
individuals don't believe in shoot first
ask questions later
governor of Aya we are the angara
these aliens are the angara the second
and final new race of Andromeda which is
honestly kind of disappointing Andromeda
is a completely new location and this
game only has two new races there are
more Milky Way races in this galaxy than
ones native to Andromeda and that's such
a missed opportunity I think most of
this is due in parts of the game's
developments but it could also be
explained away with lore despite the
fact that Andromeda takes place in the
Andromeda galaxy we're only actually in
one cluster called Helios for context in
the original trilogy we were able to
explore most of the Milky Way these dots
on the map when names are called
clusters so while the trilogy is the
whole map Andromeda is just one of these
clusters this might seem like a terrible
decision since most of the Clusters in
the trilogy only have a few locations
but don't worry it's proportional the
same depth that the Milky Way had in the
original trilogy has the same depth as
the Helios cluster the reason I bring
this up is because this could be a
reason as to why we only see the cat in
angara one of the most iconic clusters
in the trilogy is the local cluster
which houses our own solar system in
real life even though many alien species
exist in the Milky Way you'll likely
find most if not only humans since
that's our home system this might be the
reason why we only see two races in
Andromeda or maybe it's just a
convenient excuse regardless even if it
fits with the story having the start of
a new series only introduced two new
races is very disappointing especially
since they have the same skeletal
structure one common complaint levied at
the whole series is that most of the
aliens are humanoid in the sense that
they have two arms two legs with the
elkor and hanar being the only actual
alien species personally I don't have a
problem with this as much as others
might but I would love to see more
alien-like creatures as it adds a lot of
diversity to the Galaxy seeing as we've
already met the angara we should
probably talk about their backstory but
there is surprisingly not a ton of
information even though the codex has 15
separate pages on the angara their
culture and specific members among the
species most of it is unimportant I
could get deep in how the angara's
economy is similar to our modern day
capitalistic society that also employs
some informal bartering systems but most
of you including myself wants to see
what makes the angara so special what
separates them from the rest of the
Galaxy most of this lack of knowledge is
due to the cat destroying a lot of their
culture in the process of fulfilling
their end goal which we'll discuss soon
but once again that could just be a
convenient excuse to hide the fact that
the team didn't really have enough time
to flesh them out the most interesting
part about the angara is that they're
very open and are Community Driven
they're very open with their emotions
and oftentimes say exactly how they're
feeling the angara also have very large
families consisting of various mothers
cousins and relatives they also believe
in reincarnation in the sense that when
an angara dies they are reincarnated and
the Soul stays within the family they
were born from Furthermore will not a
religious figure the most shy of the
angara are revered amongst the species
before the invasion of the catch the
angara had quite a few Moshi but now
Moshi sepha is the only one that we know
of she is an elder scientist and is the
leading researcher regarding anything to
do with the cat and the remnant and has
gone through Great Lengths in order to
ensure her species Survival by using
this knowledge but the angara are not
without their faults the biggest being
the rokar a military faction within the
angara while the angaran resistance was
formed to push back the ket the Roka or
a xenophobic group that wants to drive
out any species that aren't angara out
of the Helios cluster including the
newly arrived Milky Way colonists this
is just about all the necessary
information that is needed to understand
the angara there is one very huge detail
about their culture that's revealed
later but what it could mean is mostly
speculation I'm admittedly a little
disappointed that there aren't more
unique details that set the Gengar apart
especially in the visual Department
another strange part about the angara is
that not only do they know about the
Andromeda initiative and the other
species already but that this planet we
arrive on called Aya is their Homeworld
alright well technically it's not given
the info we learned later but still the
main Hub where most of the angara reside
is Aya the first Contact between us and
the cat was much more exhilarating than
the one with the angara was we basically
just arrived on their Homeworld that are
not only paraded through the city but
also talked to like we have good
intentions in all fairness we do but the
angara constantly talk about not
trusting us since the last group they
trusted was the cat I was personally
expecting a bit more hostility and at
least some kind of build up when it came
to visiting the crown jewel of their
society it's also never officially
mentioned to my knowledge by the angara
no of us before we even meet them but it
could be that they found some Exiles
that left the Nexus and thus were able
to learn more about us before we met
still this is the player's first
introduction to them and feels rather
uneventful
back to the topic at hand the reason
we're here is to gain access to the
vaults but the angara obviously don't
trust us so we have to earn their favor
by showing them that we mean no harm
there are two other angaran planets
where tasked with going to havarl and
vold once we arrive we must talk to the
researchers and the resistance
respectively these missions are honestly
terrible on their own but there's a
reason for this we'll go over this more
on the side content section but the main
planets we visit are explorable so it's
intended that the player go to the
planet and do some side missions that
are placed there rather than just
leaving right away joining us on these
missions is jaw and angaran fighter and
our last companion for now he's here to
observe us and report his thoughts to
ephra the resistance leader but once
these missions are done he'll
permanently join us in our fight against
the cat the quest on havarl is super
easy as we're tasma going to the main
research base and rescuing some of the
researchers that seem to be trapped in
some kind of stasis field I'm fairly
certain that this is the only time
something like this occurs in the game
which is a shame but getting them out
requires us to play some Sudoku once
they're free we can return to the base
and then head off to the next planet
vold has a few more probably because
it's four times bigger than it but the
main objective is to meet the resistance
then rescue some of their members who
were captured by the cat while doing
this though you'll be given a side quest
involving this area to the Northeast
this place used to be an ancient angaran
city before the ice and the cat took it
over getting the shield down is going to
require you to eliminate the main cat
base here on vold and then enter once
the power is shut down inside the base
is more angaran prisoners but after
talking with one of them we discovered
that something is hiding behind the
walls and after blowing a hole through
it we can find an interface that used to
control the City's power grid before it
was encased in ice however this is a lie
this is actually an AI that was created
by the angara the reason she's lying to
us is that not only does she not trust
us but due to her isolation she may have
gone a bit insane she also claims to not
know anything about the angara and their
ancient history furthermore both jaw and
the prisoners have no knowledge of this
AI or any AI for that matter with an
angaran Society it is possible that
she's lying considering she was an AI
for an ancient city the angara no longer
control but it's also possible that she
was made by the Jardin to over see the
angara and that's why she has no
knowledge of them I know that is a bit
confusing since I haven't mentioned the
Jardin yet so don't worry I'll come back
to this comment later before we're given
a chance to talk though one of the
prisoners attempts to retrieve her so
that they can study her but she decides
to kill him so now we must make a choice
we can either kill her and save the
prisoner or retrieve her and kill the
prisoner this is a very rachni
queen-esque Choice especially since the
AI is showing signs of sentience so it
could be a semi- difficult decision to
make sadly though there isn't much of an
outcome to any of these choices the only
difference though comes from saving her
if we keep her then we can take her to
the angara who help us temporarily in
the final mission or take her back to
the Nexus where she can occasionally
talk to Sam and that's about it this is
something I want to talk about more
later at the end of the video but since
Andromeda is only one game it's hard to
discuss the choices of this entry since
just about all of them have minimal
impact on the game itself I can
definitely see the choice regarding the
AI coming back to bite us in a sequel
but since there's no sequel as of it
it's really hard to evaluate it one
thing I did appreciate though is that
this mission is completely option
finding the AI is not something you have
to do so there's a chance you'll miss
this during your playthrough since the
main mission is completed upon rescuing
these prisoners to be fair though it's
highly unlikely that this will happen
since the mission is completed right in
the middle of talking with a prisoner
who asks you to deliver something to
someone who then points you towards the
cat base and eventually the AI so the
game does drag you towards this
confrontation with the AI but the fact
that it's not 100 guaranteed is quite
bold and extremely commendable as I've
always appreciated when developers are
willing to make content knowing not many
people will see it they could have
easily made this a hard requirement for
the story but they opted not to which
was nice especially because now it means
we have three options available one
where we save the AI another where we
kill her and a third where we never find
her once you're finished or bored with
these planets you can return to ephra to
hear his thoughts on our mission ephra
is extremely stubborn but he recognizes
that we are a valuable asset during
these missions Rider will find out that
the Moshi is gone and was taken to a cat
facility not only is this just bad in
general but it's a lucky break for Ryder
as rescuing her would easily make him
look good in the eyes of the angara to
do this though we'll need to go back to
fold and meet up with some of the
resistance members who'll be joining us
on the mission once we break into the
facility though things start to feel off
the base is covered in religious
structures and scripture we also end up
walking in on a ritual of sorts we also
see groups of Vanguard willingly obeying
the cat which is even more strange the
leader of this ritual is a cat called
the Cardinal who talks about something
called exaltation a little further in is
where we see this so-called exaltation
foreign
[Music]
so the cat we've spent hours killing are
likely other and garans this rightfully
upsets Joel and he's having trouble
juggling with the fact that not only are
the cats stealing his people but he's
been killing his own kind the whole time
now we could get into the logistics
about whether or not a cat that used to
be in angaran is still in angaran but at
the very least the angara are being
forced to fight their own kind in some
way now that we've covered the most
important detail about the cat however
we should probably talk a bit more about
them seeing as they are the game's main
antagonists the cat is the first alien
race we find here in Andromeda but they
do not seem to be native to the Helios
cluster since the game is only in one
cluster it's hard to determine where
they come from but we do know that it's
not from this system we also know that
there is a chain of command within the
cat as the archon who is the main bad
guy of the game is just the leader of
this task force there are likely other
archons and other systems with higher
ups existing elsewhere in Andromeda it's
unclear what this chain of command is
though as like I said the archon is as
high as we go in this game in regards to
the Helios cluster the cat arrived here
around 75 years ago and immediately
began fighting the angara since their
main goal is the the exaltation of all
species the reason they do this
exultation ritual is that they're unable
to create cat naturally so this is their
only method of reproduction this is
likely due to the species stagnating
over time since they not only exalt
beings to create Marquette but also
study each species involved in the
process so they could take their best
traits later in the game we'll raid the
archon ship and we'll find some audio
logs that are about the Milky Way races
and what their best traits are as you
would expect the archon took a liking to
the krogan's tough physique but he's
also quite fond of the asari melding
process as it could be an alternative
method of reproduction for them he also
likes the turgans for their militaristic
determination which he thinks could help
with obedience the solarion's ability to
think walk and talk fast allowing the
cat to multitask and as always humans
continue to annoy everyone in the Galaxy
since their DNA is so diverse it's hard
to isolate one specific trait as such
the archon determines that only to find
a specific Champion amongst the humans
in order to get their best traits likely
meaning Rider similar to the Reapers we
know that they have done this ritual to
other species but it's unclear what
species specifically and how long
they've been doing this since in in
combat some of the cat have invisibility
and they also have a few animals in
their military that they don't seem to
be of cat origin and are likely other
alien species that they have exalted on
that ship we talked about previously is
what the game calls a behemoth which is
just an exalted Krogan while its form
seems to be intentional the behemoth's
mind is Warped thanks to the experiments
as the Krogan blood rage is interfering
with the cat DNA making it a Mindless
being who attacks anything on site just
from these details alone the cat do
sound like interesting antagonists and
they are for the most part but what
bothers me is a lack of motivation and
that this is just once again a rehashing
of old ideas the cat taking people and
turning them into cat are like the
Reapers harvesting people and turning
them into Reapers the only difference is
their reasoning the Reapers did this so
they could gain more numbers in order to
fulfill their actual goal of preventing
synthetic life from wiping out organic
life the cats seem to be doing this
because of reproduction but we have no
idea what their population is if there
are trillions of cat across the Galaxy
then it's clear they're only doing this
for Pure greed but if there are only a
couple million then it's out of
desperation the problem though is that
we never know how how many there are and
we don't even need a real number the
archon can just have a one-off line that
says the prevention of our own
Extinction is what drives us to do what
we do because as of right now they're
just doing it for the sake of it and
while I don't mind a bad guy for the
sake of bad guy kind of antagonist Not
only would I literally prefer anything
but that but I really don't consider
them to be of that kind of status the
reapers are a large extremely Advanced
beings that were very clearly above us
in power they could easily have been our
overlords due to their strength so if
their reasoning was simply just to kill
for the sake of killing then that would
make sense in fact judging from a lot of
forum posts about the game I know a lot
of people actually wanted that since
their motivation ruined a lot of the
mystery the cat though are just kind of
like any other race in the game they
don't come with that sort of horror that
the Reapers impose plus if we were to
include gameplay in this discussion then
the cat aren't that powerful at all we
needed everyone on board to destroy the
first Reaper we fought but the cat can
easily be destroyed by Ryder's Squad the
final mission does have a full-scale War
occur which I'll talk about later but
from the very beginning of the game up
until the end it never felt like the cat
were as powerful as the game made them
out to be the game wants them to be like
the Reapers in terms of power scaling
but they're just as strong as the Geth
and even this wouldn't even be a problem
though if the cat weren't the main
antagonist of the game like how the Geth
were originally the main threats until
we met Sovereign but once again as we'll
see with the ending Andromeda gives us
no indication that there is anything
higher than the cats other than their
chain of command this makes it seem like
the cat are going to be the main bad
guys of the series going forward
after dealing with the cat inside the
facility we can eventually find the
Moshi who's being held hostage by the
Cardinal once we defeat the Cardinal
we're then given another Choice cutter
closing in on the facility and inside
this facility is thousands of angarans
who haven't been exalted yet the main
objective was to blow up the facility
and get the most shy out but we can also
rescue the angara who are still trapped
here assuming we have enough time
joining us in this discussion is also
the Cardinal somehow since she's not
dead but her speech also brings up a
really good point about the story and
one I wouldn't mind seeing explored the
Cardinal claims that just like Rider she
too was tainted until she was exalted
and now realizes the gift that was
bestowed upon her so the Cardinal used
to be in angaran or some other species
prior to becoming ket this complained to
some story beat about how the higher-ups
of the cat are brainwashing those
beneath them in order to further their
agenda and are just disguised against
some sort of religious ritual now in all
honesty the game gives you zero
indication that this is the case and I'm
definitely theorizing but I'm really
trying to give the main quest the
benefit of the doubt here as I feel like
one small idea could change the entire
story for the better just like the a AI
this choice so far only affects the
final mission if we destroy the facility
then the Cardinal is killed but if we
choose to save the angara then we have
the option of sparing the Cardinal now I
can't think of a single good reason to
spare her but I'm definitely open to
discussing it in the comments one thing
I haven't mentioned though that may have
confused you is why the Moshi wasn't
exalted if the cat really wanted to
break the angara exalting her should
have been the top priority but the
reason why is because the archon needs
her the archon to his own detriment is
obsessed with Remnant technology he
wants to be able to use it to further
the end goal of exaltation that's
because he eventually became aware of a
place called Meridian the true core of
the vaults activating this Meridian
would give someone control of all the
vaults in the Helios cluster the archon
plans to use it as a means of surrender
basically either the people of the
cluster surrender to exaltation or die
due to the vaults ruining the planet's
ecosystem the only problem though is
that while he knows the location of
Meridian he can't access it which is why
he wanted to find Alec Ryder the only
thing I'm a bit confused about though is
how he's going to pull this off since
through our knowledge all the vaults are
disabled so turning them off would
either do nothing since they're already
off or we just take the current planet's
ecosystem and turn them back to what
they were originally were like how EOS
had radiation hazards throughout the map
before we activated the Vault the Codex
does state that the vaults can also
cause damage further than just being
turned off like how habitat 7 had
lightning striking the planet's surface
but it was never explicitly stated that
the Vault was the cause of the damage if
I recall it was something about how the
vaults and the cloud was in a feedback
loop so it didn't seem like it was the
actual Vault being the core problem that
being said though if it is possible for
the vaults to be damaged like this one
then that would indeed be a problem
regardless though his obsession with the
remnant technology has created a rift
amongst the cat as many of the cat both
under his command and above him are
questioning his intentions and whether
or not he's doing this for the good of
the cat people his second in command the
Primus is even having doubts and will
contact us at one point to strike a deal
during a side mission so it's very clear
that the remnant Tech is either located
only within the Helios cluster or is
across the Galaxy but the archon is the
only one that we know of that actually
cares about this technology so now the
goal is to find the location of this
meridian so we can stop the archon and
also use the control center for our own
purposes as while it has the chance to
destroy all the planets thereon it can
also heal all the planets allowing us to
colonize the planets quicker to find
Meridian though we're going to need to
find the archon ship and to do that
we're going to need to talk to someone
that's willing to give us the
information sadly the cat aren't going
to talk but according to the Moshi effer
has been withholding the fact that the
Moshi was not just taken by the kept by
pure chance but that nangaran Soldier
gave her location to the cat this
soldier's name is Van terev who's
located on kadara originally an angaran
planet that is now home to most of the
Exiles from the Nexus but with this
Mission finished Jal has officially
joined the group and has now become our
last companion so let's take a quick
break from the main quest to talk about
the crew just like with the previous
games Andromeda has a list of companions
we can talk and interact with but I'm
reluctant to call this section companion
since Andromeda places a bit more
importance on the other crew of the ship
compared to previous games the Normandy
in the original trilogy was a large ship
with an equally large crew the problem
though is that many of the crew were
unnamed Alliance soldiers that never
said a word of dialogue The Tempest on
the other hand is much smaller and thus
has a smaller crew but now we can talk
to every single person aboard the ship
that's also why I want to call this
section crew because just talking about
the companions is basically getting us
90 of the way there anyway as the other
four members that are not a part of our
fire team are engineer Gail Brody
medical doctor Lexi de pero pilot callow
and scientist Dr suvi Anwar but since
they aren't a part of the companions
they'll have less screen time which is
why I wanted to cover them now Dr Lexi
de perro probably has the least to say
on the Tempest but that's because she's
committed to her job as the ship's
medical doctor when asked she's able to
give psych reports on the crew and can
also give us opinions on the missions we
have embarked on while not incredibly
interesting she's nice to talk to and
she also brings up a good point about
romance in the previous games romance
was quite obvious either you flirt with
them or you can't in this game you can
flirt with Lexi which will turn you down
if she wants to keep things professional
between you two it's a small change but
the fact that we can flirt with her and
get turned down is a nice addition as
with the other games once you've flirted
with them you knew that meant that they
were an option in Andromeda though that
may not be the case but this doesn't
just extend to non-romanceable options
but also gender specific options like
Gail Brody Gil is only an option for
male Rider if you attempt to flirt with
him as Sarah he'll turn you down saying
that guys like Liam are more his style
as I said I'm a really big fan of this
realistic portrayal of romance Gill is
an engineer of the ship so he'll be in
the back making sure things go smoothly
however he does start to have some
issues with callow Cal was not only the
ship's pilot but also one of the few
solarians that actually built the
Tempest Gill and Calo Clash over this as
callow claims that the Tempest was
designed to do exactly what it's
supposed to do bitco claims that the
Tempest needs changing to fit with their
current predicament these two will
eventually go back and forth before
eventually coming to a final
confrontation where you get to decide
who's in the right ultimately the choice
doesn't really change much but it does
go back to what I said before about the
additional crew having more screen time
in this entry kello also has something
quite appealing about him that other
companions have and that's what I'll
call infinite dialogue basically you can
ask callow about the ship and its many
stories you can ask this as many times
you want and even come back at different
points in the story to hear more about
them drak and Cora have similar dialogue
as well but it's about their individual
War Stories I really like this inclusion
as it can deepen the connection between
you and the companion you're talking to
now saying its infinite dialogue is
definitely a hyperbole but I never found
any repetitive lines even after dozen
stories so all of it for me was unique
returning to Gill he and suvi are the
only two of the four that have actual
missions since they are romanceable
admittedly though they are quite short
Gill will occasionally talk about his
friend Jill Jill is trying to reignite
the first three population effort and is
starting it back on EOS Gail is a bit
conflicted though but having children of
his own as like his dad he always does
things without looking back that being
said though everything seems to work out
pretty okay as it's discovered that Jill
is pregnant and wants Rider and Guild to
be the kid's dads so Gil is able to get
a happy relationship with the person he
loves and is also able to care for a
child
as for suvi she intrigued me from the
moment I met her and I promise you it's
not entirely because of her voice
although Ryder and I are definitely in
agreeance on that I'm really glad you
volunteered to join our crew by the way
I am too
you Galaxy and all I'm honored to be
here
no I mean
I think you're cute and I like seeing
you up here oh my goodness Ryder also
the accent the accent is I mean it's not
the only thing but uh okay I should just
go over there to the piloting thing kill
me
what actually attracted me to her though
was her interest in both science and
Faith most people see it as a sort of
either or kind of thing where you either
believe God created us or you believe in
something like the theory of evolution
suvi believes in both science and in
faith and has always had trouble
explaining that to people her parents
got her into the Sciences but she also
found a deep appreciation for God since
those two often conflict though she was
struggling with her beliefs you can of
course appreciate her commitment to her
faith or poke fun at her for it but
assuming you want to romance her you
join her on the Nexus for some brief
alone time both of these two are nice
romance options but their quests are
definitely not anything to write home
about since there isn't a whole lot that
happens I am glad though that BioWare
took more time to make additional crew
more important and also gave them
genuine personalities as while the
romances were quite short and we didn't
get to talk to them all that much I did
take a liking to them and I do hope the
next Mass Effect game puts more emphasis
on the other crew of the Normandy as for
our actual companions let's start from
the beginning like every mass of that
game our first two companions are both
human those two being Liam and Cora Liam
falls into the same trap as many of the
other human companions but Cora ended up
surprising me Liam has a sort of basic
human backstory except it's not like in
previous games where they start in the
alliance or something Liam hopped around
different jobs and careers originally
going to school for engineering before
going into law enforcement he then
eventually left that career to join
hustle a multi-species crisis response
team you can really piece together from
your talks with Liam that he's supposed
to be the comedic relief and doesn't
really think before acting this is
reflected in your few interactions with
him on the ship Liam wants to know more
about Joel and the angaran people so he
decides the best way to do that is to
swap armor and insult each other Liam
had y'all learn our insults and what
things offend us and then later Liam
took his turn Liam's ideas are always
Noble but the methods in which he does
them are always bizarre which is a
perfect way to explain his character
this continues even into his loyalty
mission where he learns that some angara
that he was communicating with was
captured he wanted to bridge the gap
between the Milky Way and the angara by
being more open with them so Liam
decided to share a secret of Nexus data
with his contact but now she's captured
and her captor has that info this was
incredibly stupid of him to do but once
again his idea was Noble he was sick of
the initiative being seen as The
Outsiders and wanted to make Andromeda
his home along with the rest of the
initiative so he wanted to bridge that
Gap but couldn't go through the proper
channels which is why he took things
into his own hands rescuing his contact
verand is really where it becomes clear
that he is supposed to be a comedic
relief
I'm just here blind we don't know where
anyone is or how anything was and now
we're fighting some who wants
everyone chained it's like hitting
Andromeda all over again a shield of it
don't make this about the whole
initiative we're here to help and why am
I the one defending your plan I don't
know
I will not be ignored anymore
see total once you finish his
mission and rescue his contact though
you can talk to Liam and discuss what
happened
look I'm not a huge fan of Liam I'd say
he's probably the worst companion in
this game but I did like that his
character was built around this guy
who's in way over his head trying to do
things he believes are good but ends up
failing at every step Liam is trying to
take all the problems in Andromeda and
put them on his own shoulders because
it's a part of the Pathfinder's team he
thinks every problem is his problem
doing this Mission though screws his
head on tight he then decides to play an
event for the colonists of EOS and I
gotta admit a game of soccer is a really
good way to get people together the
pitch is looking less than ideal given
it's all covered in sand but people have
played in much worse conditions this is
also where you can lock in your romance
with Liam and assuming you do the two of
you will go into a really tall structure
on EOS and jump off together Liam asks
you before this mission to make a
modified jump jet with some specific
schematics and it's discovered that
those changes make the air form in the
shape of a heart as corny as that is not
only does this fit Liam perfectly it is
admittedly kinda cute this Mission
though is also when drama is next and
probably biggest change when it comes to
Companions and that's romance missions
Romance is not really something we've
mentioned much in the series because we
really never needed to we all know what
happens during a romance scene with
Andromeda though romance is more than
just a simple sex scene while Leah may
not be a great example the other
companions are such as vetro who will
try to cook dinner for Ryder but
realizes she's not that great at it or
Joel who takes the two to a secluded hot
spring on Aya usually the cast would
just be called up to the Captain's
Quarters and then they further their
relationship in Andromeda the crew is
actively going out of their way to do
stuff for you so they can show how much
they care about you and your
relationship together which is really
sweet getting back to our order we can
now move on to Cora she likes suvi did a
really good job of attracting me to her
but in this instance it was because of
her gameplay when of course skill trees
is asari Commando which confused me
since she's not an asari thankfully she
clears this up and says that her biotics
manifested at a young age but since
humans don't really have a protocol for
these things except the biotic camps
like Kaden went to she was treated much
differently from her peers people were
also nervous to be around her since she
was not only powerful but unstable since
she had no idea how to control her
powers the alliance then sent her to a
cross-species initiative and eventually
trained as a Huntress anthesia the asari
Homeworld if the backstory of a human
being an asari Huntress doesn't interest
you in the slightest then good luck as
this is korra's entire personality it's
definitely unique and I was quite fond
of her backstory but I don't think there
was a single conversation where she
doesn't mention something about the
asari even her loyalty mission is
dedicated to them as she wants us to
find the asari arc that went missing one
thing I did like about core though is
that initially she doesn't like us
assuming Alec Ryder followed the chain
of command Cora was actually supposed to
be the Pathfinder but since we took that
position she feels cheated out of the
opportunity even questioning whether or
not we're worthy to hold that title this
may also be why her dedicated spot on
the Nexus is the Pathfinder's office
when visiting the Nexus we can find the
crew and talk to them and Cora's always
here in a place that's only supposed to
be for other Pathfinders so I'm
wondering if this is BioWare showing us
that Cora still believes that she should
be a Pathfinder and thus thinks that she
belongs in the Pathfinder headquarters
as for why Cora joined the initiative
well unlike Liam she wasn't exactly
raring to go she was actually told by
her mentor to leave and that the
initiative suited her better it's
unclear whether her Mentor harbertson
Prejudice regarding a human being an
asari Commando or if she genuinely meant
well but it definitely her Korra a lot
thankfully Alec Ryder though saw her
potential and gave her a chance that's
why she's so hurt about the Pathfinder
role because she looks up to Alec as he
saw something in her that no one else
did and having him not only die but have
her Destin roll slip through her fingers
due to us being related to Alec really
affects her relationship with us after
some time though core does eventually
come around to realize that we are the
best person for the job which is mostly
attributed to us stopping the archon but
also helping her find the asari arc
after quite a lot of waiting researching
and talking Cora will eventually find
the location of the Ark and want us to
save them this is also where I started
to get a bit annoyed at her as almost
all her dialogue made me cringe when she
was speaking about the asari manuals and
also how she had to constantly mention
that she knows the asari lingo
Ryder I hadn't heard you with the asari
Pathfinder the last we knew ma'am
matriarch ashara was Pathfinder with you
acting as her tiamna
I served with the sorry Commandos ma'am
memorized all your battle manuals
pray the power will be enough for FTL I
just
vdaria I served as a Huntress remember
cyrissa's manuals breathe purpose action
breathe
okay it's the cat
the Daria can't face them she's not a
Huntress without the trust of her TEAM
stands alone
she is a tree in the desert bearing only
Defiance my own words Lieutenant they're
true
ma'am it honestly just became way too
much for me I went from cringing to just
straight up laughing at that last line
because I couldn't believe how much bio
were committed to this bit I do like
Cora's backstory because it is a unique
twist that we haven't seen before in a
human companion especially since we've
already had a few biotic humans already
but having it be her whole personality
sometimes went a bit over the line the
reason she said that last line though is
because it's learned that cyrissa got
the original asari Pathfinder killed by
disobeying her the Pathfinder at the
time was matriarch ishara she was
attempting to hold her ground and by
code sarisa is supposed to defend her
since she was her bodyguard cerissa
refused though and determined that the
cap module she found would help the
asari defeat the cat she then abandoned
her post in order to make sure the
module was Secure so the final choice is
deciding whether or not cyrissa was in
the right to do so if you believe that
she's not fit to be Pathfinder then
vaderia the rookie we met earlier
becomes the new Pathfinder while the
specific person has no impact on the
story having the asari Pathfinder at all
does so not doing this Mission changes
one part of the final mission once you
complete her loyalty Mission though
Coral will also ask you to join her on
EOS as she has a surprise you then learn
that Korra has some seeds that she wants
to plant with the hope that one day
they'll Blossom on EOS her quarters are
in the bio room which is covered in
planned so it's no secret that she wants
to start a garden the two of you can
then kiss and make the relationship a
bit more than just being friends of
course romance Mission also surprised me
because we're actually given the option
to take things slow Korra claims that
there's a problem in the Captain's
Quarters and that we should check it out
alone obviously this is just an excuse
for her and Rider to have some alone
time and we'll do what couples do behind
closed doors clearly I'm not going going
to show any of it because YouTube would
have a Fit Plus Andromeda shows a hell
of a lot more than I expected regardless
that's not the point because instead of
doing the deed you can just deny her and
so that you don't really want to go
further just yet that doesn't mean
you're breaking up or anything it's just
that you don't want to have sex just yet
quite a few of the companions have this
option and the romance will change
because of this instead of doing the
deed both Korra and Ryder stargaze and
his quarters it's a really welcome
change for those who aren't into having
intercourse or for those who want to
take things slow there is a chance that
you like me will never actually use this
option but it's the thought that counts
adding more choices is something I'm
never going to complain about even if I
wouldn't choose those options myself
after Liam and Cora though the next
three that we meet are Vetra PB and Drac
Vetra is a female Tyrion born on Paladin
but wasn't really recognized as a part
of the culture as she never enlisted in
boot camp when she was old enough as we
know turians are all about discipline
and Military so going against that can
have a huge impact on their social life
to make matters worse veterans home life
was just as depressing her mother only
cared about her status in the military
and her father was a shady businessman
that ultimately left the family when she
was young her only true friend was her
younger sister Sid before he left though
their father took the pair away before
leaving them to fend for themselves a
few years later this really hardened
Vetra and turned her into the woman she
is today as the older sister she endured
lots of hardship and had to raise Sid on
her own despite being only a few years
older than her eventually she ran some
missions with a Merc group and ended up
getting caught by their owner they were
stealing from who just so happened to be
cash as punishment for stealing veter
worked for cash in exchange for her
freedom and through that the two
developed a mutual friendship this
friendship is what led to Vetra and Sid
joining the initiative because cash
referred them to Nexus command the two
then accepted the idea since they wanted
to leave everything that happened back
then behind just in case it ever caught
up with them despite that though vetro
is on our ship and not on the Nexus so
what gives Liam and Cora were already a
part of the Pathfinder team so they were
going to be on the ship regardless Vetra
willingly came along though that's
because Vetra believes she can be of use
to us she knows the crew knows the ship
and is very good at holding her own
after some time vetcher will come to
Ryder with an issue though Sid has some
information she wants to share which is
that some settlers went missing and she
wants us to find them Vetra is not
convinced though since when asked if the
intel was reliable Sid just replies yes
she doesn't even bother to explain where
she got it from or from who once we
arrive at the nav point we realize that
Sid was telling the truth but it's too
late as the team falls into a trap they
like the settlers are now trapped and
can't escape the person kidnapping these
people is a person named Meriwether who
claims to know Vetra this is because Sid
was playing the part of Vetra so that
she could use her contacts and do some
good the mission is honestly quite
boring and I wasn't really a huge fan of
it but the narrative implications make
the whole story of Vetra a lot more
compelling Vetra has been trying to
raise Sid to be the best that she can be
but to do that she needed to do some
shady things in order to survive Sid
just being a child saw this and was
awestruck because she looked up to her
sister and wanted to do what she did but
veteran wouldn't allow it since she
knows the dangers that come from her job
but of course you know how this stuff
goes the more you're told not to do
something the more you want to do it
which is why Sid took it upon herself to
rescue these people and do things that
her sister did this would ultimately
catch up to her though with this Mission
as she has quite the brush with death
before veteran Rider save her Sid and
Vetter then get into an argument about
the whole ordeal and even though she was
moments away from Death Sid chalks it up
as a win and actually she wants to
continue doing this despite Vetra
vehemently disagreeing eventually though
you and Vetra can also Advance your
relationship by going rock climbing
together afterward she'll then surprise
you with a steak dinner but it's not too
great she apologizes for ruining the
moments but Ryder clearly doesn't care
and just wants to spend time with her
Veteran's attitude completely changes
throughout the course of these missions
Vetra talks about wanting to be an
honest person and doesn't want to be an
to people anymore anyone in her
situation would want the same if you
lived your whole childhood running from
people and stealing equipment for scraps
all you would want is a life of peace
and as her partner you can not only show
her the beauty of that life but also be
the one to give it to her
while veteran may want a different life
drak is more than content with his drak
is atypical Krogan in regards to his
personality but I like the way they
implemented this into the game Draco
like all Crogan talks about killing
fighting and shooting but unlike someone
like dagger Reeve where it's overplayed
in Bland her Dracut makes sense Drac is
over one thousand years old he remembers
fighting in the Racine Wars and was
there when the genophage was first
deployed on the Krogan colonies being
stuck in his ways doesn't even begin to
describe him fighting for a long time
inevitably come with scars and wounds
and just like before that doesn't even
begin to describe it there is a good
chance that Drax body is more synthetic
than organic his arm leg hip internal
organs and even his spine are held
together by implants and wiring he's
basically on death's door but somehow
this old man is still kicking but he
wasn't always this chipper about his
life oftentimes the implants he was
given wouldn't sink well so he wasn't
able to use them so while he would wait
for new ones to come in he was in
intense pain it dragged him into some
pretty dark places and he almost felt
like giving up until one of the shaman
and his clan gave him a base Krogan the
shaman claimed that the girl was going
to die and was useless to the clan but
drak was determined to prove them wrong
so he raised her as his granddaughter
until she was able to live on her own
the best part is we've already met his
granddaughter it's cash going from faded
to die to the board of directors on the
Nexus is definitely something to be
proud of and I'm sure drak feels the
same way similar to callow draken shares
some stories with us most of which are
from his 1000 years of combat experience
and as you would expect the retreat to
Listen to As for his loyalty Mission
drack wants us to locate a guy named
spender on the Nexus as it seems like
he's been conducting some shady business
we get a look at the security footage
but not much is able to be deciphered
minus a few shots of kedara Ryder and
crew then learn that spender has been
smuggling things off the Nexus that he
can deliver them to the Exiles when they
investigate his room and while we don't
find much a data pack gives us a teaser
of the events to come because after
enough time Drac will have some urgent
news for Ryder Jack wants us to look
into the seed Vault that was stolen from
one of the Krogan transports this
transport also happened to have a Krogan
named vorn on it who's a a botanist and
was tasked with making sure these seed
vaults operate properly but now he and
the Vault are gone Krogan children need
these plants in order to survive so this
isn't about Drac anymore it's about the
survival of the Krogan Dragon Rider then
tracked the Smugglers to a remote base
and managed to save voran and the Vault
while this is going on they learned that
the head Smuggler is named arone and
Drac realizes that spender is involved
again we also get a chance to talk with
vorn and realize that he's taking a
liking to Kesh something a Drac is taken
aback by once the team kills our own and
saves default track has a chat with
Ryder and mentions how he thinks his
time is up the seed vault is going to
help new Krogan who are going to have a
new future and it's something Jack
thinks he shouldn't be a part of he
thinks of himself as a relic of the past
something that shouldn't be in the
present but we can tell him that while
he's getting old he can still help those
Krogan children enjoy their new life
which is something he agrees with
afterward though we can meet him on the
Nexus and arrest spender he's then
arrested or considered an exile whatever
you prefer and dracon you celebrate by
having a bar fight on kadara playing
some Krogan games and even finding out
that cash is pregnant Drac is easily my
favorite companion in the game he has
such a unique personality and backstory
that set him apart from the rest of the
crew and listening to his past was
always something I welcomed whereas Aid
sort of embodied that Uncle that told
you stories about his past during family
gatherings Drac is the grandpa that
fought in the old world wars and could
ramble on for days about the years he
served and has these scars to prove it I
really took a liking to him and if
there's a sequel I would love to see
where his story goes
been coming
hi PB is the other companion we meet on
EOS and as I said before an extroverted
Liara is the perfect description for her
we first meet her while learning about
the vaults and she joins us for that
entire Mission she then just like Liara
realizes that if they join the
protagonist they'll be able to find out
more about the species they are studying
like all companions each of the crew
picks a specific place to hunker down
but instead of the med Bay or storage
room PB chooses the Escape pod trust is
something she struggles with she's
always looking for Escape Routes in any
situation even if it's as something as
mundane as hanging out at the bar it
becomes pretty clear though that PB has
no intention of staying she says that
while the Escape pod doesn't feel like
home that's what she likes about it
since she doesn't want to have a home BB
is willing to help us on our mission but
she's really only here because of the
remnant during her introductory Mission
she'll find a Remnant court and wants to
uncover its secrets for a personal
project of hers this project is revealed
to be Pock a Remnant robot that she
programmed to be her buddy she also
created one for us called zap that we
can use in combat while the two are
enjoying the project they are
interrupted by Kalinda pb's
ex-girlfriend Kalinda seems hostile and
will eventually try to sabotage PB but
for now we're able to Defuse The
Situation after some time PB will start
to cause some problems she's starting to
feel trapped and stressed out since
she's usually not in one place for very
long but since she's a part of the crew
she's been on the Tempest for a while to
cool herself off she usually floats in
zero g Chambers so that all that stress
can go away but there isn't one on the
ship until Sam recommends making the
Escape pod into a zero g chamber she
happily agrees that the idea and is able
to cool off for a bit Ryder can then
join her and do more than cooling off
and while this does seem quite fast PB
is a very flirtatious butterfly plus he
says this is simply just a fling no
strings attached later on in the game is
where we get her loyalty Mission and as
you would expect it involves Kalinda PB
wants us to find these Remnant pieces
across the various planets but while
doing these missions she realizes that
someone is catching on to what they're
doing they learn that it's some Krogan
called krannon 2 is tracking them before
realizing that he works for Kalinda Calo
then calls Ryder and says that someone
snuck onto the ship and stole Puck
obviously this was Kalinda eventually
they'll get parked back but unbeknownst
to them Kalinda put a tracker on the bot
in case PB finds something like an
extremely valuable piece of Remnant
technology PB then wants us to go with
her to retrieve this Tech but we have to
battle through kalinda's forces since
she's also here for that technology as
well the two then get into an
altercation and we have to choose
between saving Kalinda but losing the
tech or killing her and getting what we
came here for either option is viable
for completing the mission so it's
entirely up to you but I think saving
her is the right option as PB believes
that people dying over this piece of
tech is not worth it as for her romance
Mission well it's extremely adorable as
she starts to realize that she wants
those strings attached as long as it's
with us but she can't say it in person
so she has Pock play a pre-recorded
message while she runs out of the room
she then calls a team meeting and
apologizes for being so distant and
decides that she wants to stay with the
team all of them except her offer even
though they already did that the moment
she joined which makes her feel more
comfortable with the whole situation we
can also accept her love invitation
which sees the two spend some time alone
together in Ryder's quarters I found
this interaction really sweet as PB the
girl who never wanted a home says that
she finally found her home in Ryder
our final companion is jaw as we know
Joel is an angara and as such is able to
tell us a bit about the angaran people
which is what we talked about earlier
jaw really goes through it during the
course of this game as his people are
always fighting in Wars then he
eventually learns that the cat he's been
fighting were originally his people
Joel is very open about his emotions
regarding everything he experiences
which gives Rider a chance to be open
with him as well jaw is initially quite
reserved as at the time he's just here
to serve a writer and the crews that he
can give his thoughts to ephra but over
time he starts to see the crew as a
family which makes him feel more at home
jaw at one point even opts to make gifts
for the group he was going to give Liam
his cape and even write a poem for Vetra
at one point we asked Joel about himself
and the topic of school comes up jaw
struggles with his own personal identity
because he really doesn't know what he
wants to do in life this is made twice
as hard by the fact that Angar and
families are quite large so jaw Hears A
lot of opinions about what he should be
Jal also explains how his family comes
from a respected lineage of people all
of whom have done great things in their
life yet Joel doesn't know what to do he
knows that he wants to do something
because he wants to not because someone
told him to but he doesn't know what
that thing is yet
eventually jaw has writer help him with
a problem regarding the rokar as we
talked about earlier the rokar are a
xenophobic faction dedicated to killing
anything that isn't angara the leader of
the group is named axul he spent some
time in a cat labor camp and even though
he managed to escape a year after this
experience changed him he swore to save
the angaran people by killing anything
that wasn't them which is what birthed
the rokar Axel's mindset is clearly
tainted by this experience and his
ideals have had an effect on millions of
angarans as the rokar are a large
faction
Joel eventually gets some more troubling
news about axol and it's on that he and
The Rock are plan to attack EOS Ryder
manages to fend them off with ease with
clear that Axel is gunning for him and
it's only a matter of time until they
meet again Joel after a few missions
will then learn that Axel plans to blow
up the forge on havarl this is an
ancestral birthplace for the angara and
blowing this up will make it seem like
the initiative did this and start
another War upon entering the facility
we run into a few rokar members who just
so happen to be Jaws relatives two of
them are very gung-ho by joining the
rokar with the other being a bit more
skeptical jal's sister then takes the
opportunity to shoot the skeptical
relative before realizing she made a
mistake as the group pushes into the
facility they'll eventually catch up
with the relatives and they'll admit
that they made a mistake and don't want
to be in the rocar if it means going
against family axol then arrives just in
time to confront us and this is where
we're given the choice of shooting Axel
or not shooting will give him what he
wants EXO wants to become a martyr for
the angaran people which means more
angara will enlist letting him do as he
pleases though sees him shooting jaw he
never wanted to kill him but he was
hoping to provoke Rider into stopping
him before it happened but by not doing
anything we publicly shame Axel in front
of his men if we do end up letting Axel
live he'll email us later saying that
while he may never see non-angarans as
people he does realize that he made a
mistake as shooting jaw like fellow
angaran goes against what his original
goals were eventually after talking with
his family and returning to the ship job
will let us know that he's been promoted
within the resistance and given his own
command this is something that jaw
wanted but he ends up denying the
position being with Ryder has allowed
him to break free of expectations and
become a better person which is
something he wants more this then leads
into Jaws romance where the two go to
meet Jaws family as well as confess
their love for each other assuming you
want to if you do then draw the router
go to a remote part of Ayah that has a
hot spring and the two relax until the
following morning
Joel's Quest was fantastic and it really
shows How Deeply the cat wounded the
angara they're not only Dying by the
thousands every day but they're causing
infighting amongst their own species the
cat ever ruined so much of the angaran
culture and history and all they want is
for them to stop but the only way to do
that is to fight and fighting can be
hard especially when you're constantly
losing so you lash out and take it out
on someone just to feel relief honestly
I liked all the quests and all the
characters aboard the Tempest even the
characters I wasn't too fond of like
Liam had their memorable moments I
really like the themes that made up each
character's missions as each one was
something personal whether that be as
stuck in his ways old man who feels like
his time has come and gone a sister who
had to grow up fast to make sure her
younger sister had a life that wasn't
like hers or a guy who put all the
problems of the world on his back as he
felt like he needed to all of them had
their issues that needed to be dealt
with and going through them was a blast
and easily my favorite part of the game
that being said though Andromeda drops
the ball in one way that is detrimental
to this story and that's the removal of
the ability screen every mass of that
game has a wheel of abilities that
include both you and your companions
abilities Andromeda completely does away
with this system which is baffling if
any game should have had it it should
have been Andromeda because the game
introduces primers and detonators some
of the abilities can Prime and detonate
upon activation for example Singularity
a classic biotic skill primes the
enemies for damage by tossing them
around the charge skill is a Detonator
as this does actual damage using a
Detonator on an enemy who is primed
causes a combo to occur which results in
a specific explosion depending on the
ability used but since we can't control
our companions abilities all the combos
basically come from us other than that
it's just sheer luck while this is more
of a gameplay critique this has some
drastic consequences for the story using
these characters in combat allows us to
deepen our relationship with them I'm
sure right now you can think of one
character from the series and tell me
what their abilities are that's because
you use them enough to remember them
Garris for example in Mass Effect 2 I
believe has concussive shot and overload
with his loyalty Mission ability being
armor-piercing rounds Kasumi also has
that one ability where she goes
invisible and does some stealth attacks
which I think is called Shadow strike
that wasn't even something I wrote In
The Script I just remembered that off
the top of my head on the flip side
though I can't recall a single ability
or even weapon that the companions have
other than korra's charge and drag
shotgun you're allowed to upgrade your
companions abilities and skill trees
like the previous games but since you
can't use their abilities what's the
point of customizing it to your liking
this is a very integral part of the
series that is just gone and while I did
ultimately enjoy their missions I never
felt that same deep connection I had
with the trilogy's crew and this isn't
even due to the fact that they had
multiple games to star in many people
love Garris from the get-go same as me
and I vividly remember his abilities as
I always used him and by using him in my
fire team we grow a deeper connection as
I said I really did like the cast
despite that glaring issue and if you
remember from the Mass Effect 2 video I
also said well I love the story of the
trilogy what initially drew me to the
Mass Effect series was its unique
characters all of whom had incredible
personalities and wonderful missions and
while Andromeda doesn't allow you to
fight with them in a cohesive matter I
did like talking with them I grew to
like this new cast a lot and if this
game has a sequel in the future I would
love to see how all of them evolve over
the course of the story
returning back to the main quest we were
told by ephra and the Moshi to seek out
ten berev he was key in helping the
archon kidnap the Moshi who needed her
to access Meridian finding the archon
and his ship will hopefully mean that we
can find Meridian as well ephra tells us
that this 10 varev fella is on kedara
which is home to most of the Exiles from
the Nexus and leading them is Sloan
Kelly When we arrive on kadara we meet
with one of the angaran contacts named
Reyes he said he'll help us out just in
case things go south at the meeting with
Sloane so we then meet with Sloane and
she does well whatever this is yeah
Andromeda is quite the buggy game it's
not game breaking buggy where it's soft
locked my game or remove some of my
progress but it's the little things like
when Liam shots to the sky during his
loyalty Mission there was also the time
I fell off the map while running away
from the remnant Vault and I respawned
in my car despite that not being
possible in any capacity I also glitched
my HUD by skipping through dialogue too
fast while doing side content and my
personal favorite completely shattering
Rider's body as I said and draw wasn't
game breaking buggy at least not by my
definition anyway but there were a lot
more bugs than I thought there would be
thanks to Sloane asserting her dominance
over me by merging with the floor I
completely fumbled the meeting so she
was unwilling to help us meaning I had
to go through Reyes instead this really
doesn't matter though because you still
end up meeting Venta rev anyway it's
just whether or not you go through the
front or the back door after being
honest with him venterev tells us that
he got his orders from a cat transponder
and he thinks that Ryder can take it and
tune its frequencies that he can find
out where the order came from we then
travel around kadara and find the
transponder and come back to the Tempest
we then give the transponder to gill who
triangulates the archon's location after
entering the system we discovered that
not only were we correct and this is
indeed the archon ship but that he also
has the solarion arc Tethered to him we
then pick our fire team and land on the
ark it seems like the solarians are
losing this battle but they are and
always have been quite crafty when
backed against the wall the team aboard
the ship decided to swap the Pathfinder
with another Resident so the cat thought
they killed the solarium Pathfinder when
she's actually been in crime with the
whole time it's incredibly smart and was
easy enough for us to figure out so we
can get her back in the fight the two
Pathfinders though will have to split up
as they have two different goals the
solarium Pathfinder Reika is trying to
rescue the rest of her crew while we're
here to find the archon and hopefully
find Meridian as well on the way though
the group gets trapped by The archon Who
takes a sample of Rider's blood in hopes
of finding out why Ryder is so
proficient rather than ask Sam how to
get out who says that the containment
field only affects living beings zofrada
were to temporarily die he could escape
the containment field
as you would expect he is not
particularly interested in dying on the
small chance that Sam fails but there
doesn't seem to be any other option so
Sam stops his heart and luckily revives
him this did not come without
consequences though as now Sam is more
deeply connected to Rider via the
implant which will play out later now
that we are out we can continue our hunt
for the archon's office if you want to
you can also take the time to look
around and listen to audio logs
regarding what the archon is up to this
is where you'll learn those details
about the Milky Way and what their best
traits are according to the archon
thankfully the office is right next door
and one of the artifacts in his room
houses the coordinates for Meridian the
archon will then release one of his
specimens called the Behemoth that we
will have to defeat if you recall our
earlier conversation then you'll know
this is a modified Krogan as for why
there are Krogan here when the archon
captured a solarian ship will these
Krogan seem to be the scouts that drak
lost at one point after leaving the
Nexus the game then lets you experience
this fight so the choice right after has
more impact Pathfinder Reika is about to
be overrun and needs our help but if we
help her we won't have enough of time to
save the Krogan Scouts the consequences
for this are either more behemoths in
the final mission thanks to us leaving
them here or the solarians are down a
Pathfinder the only issue though is that
just like the asari Pathfinder the
original one gets replaced by someone
anyway there is definitely a discussion
to be had regarding whether or not we're
okay with someone who is possibly
inexperienced replacing the already
familiar Pathfinder but in terms of
actual tangible consequences I didn't
notice anything different when I saved
Reika regardless of who you rescue
though Ryder and Company return to the
Nexus we learned though that the implant
did a bit more than just take a blood
sample as it also allowed the archon to
appear into writer's memories something
that will also have an effect later on
with the destination marked we can now
head to Meridian but a few of the crew
ask us to go visit some new planets
which are called elidin and
h-047c similar to havarl and vold these
are just put here so that the player can
have a reason to explore these as the
missions aren't long in fact I'd argue
there not even missions
whereas a viral involved made you at
least complete one Quest all you need to
do here is land and then go back to the
Tempest and the mission is complete
I didn't mind how varal involved as I
felt like they Blended in with the main
content quite well but this doesn't
elidin h047c and even kadara provides
zero substance to the story the main
quest just had you go here because the
devs wanted you to explore the rest of
the planet you could easily put that
mission with event to Rev on a different
planet and it changes nothing pavaral
and vold are and guard planets and at
that point in the story we are trying to
earn their favor so it made sense to go
here
h047c is also completely useless because
it's not even one of the five planets we
can actually set up outposts for you can
clear the entire planet in about an hour
and the visual design is lacking and
seeing as I'm already rambling about the
side content and we're about to approach
the point of no return anyway might as
well talk about what there is to do when
not doing the main quest here in
Andromeda site content in Mass Effect
Andromeda depending on what we're
talking about is honestly quite good the
major one being Planetary Exploration as
Pathfinder we're tasked with making
planets habitable and also building
outposts what we did on EOS is basically
what we'll be doing on other planets
activate the monoliths activate the
Vault then build an outpost besides that
though there are a ton of other things
we can do on the planets if you played
any open world game like the most recent
God of Wars any Ubisoft game in the past
decade and a dozen of other examples I
could probably use then you know how
this works when comparing and drama to
side content to other games like the
ones we just mentioned not much is
different but in terms of Mass Effect
this is the best one we've seen so far
that being said though there are a
couple things I'm not too happy with the
two biggest problems with this system is
that some of the maps are just too big
and there's no sense of mystery on a lot
of these planets the two things Mass
Effect 1 Excel that but that the planets
ever felt like they overstayed their
welcome and that they gave off this
sense of loneliness the feeling that we
were possibly the only people on this
planet at the time and Andromeda though
doesn't have this some of the maps are
too big for their own good a perfect
example is once again h047c which is
literally just a giant rock and elidin
which while pretty has about 80 percent
of its area covered in nothing but sand
this honestly wouldn't even be a problem
on its own if there was something to
explore there but more often than not
you'll be driving around for quite a
while without anything catching her eye
the planets are already big as is so
making them bigger and not adding any
content there is very confusing to me
the planets are also covered in NPCs
removing the sense of loneliness Mass
Effect 1 instilled even though we aren't
a completely new Galaxy with dozens of
undocumented planets to explore people
have already made it their home EOS is
the only planet that genuinely fits all
the criteria for a perfect Planet what a
coincidence that it's the first one we
explore almost like that was intentional
it started to feel like the quality was
dropping every time I explored a new
planet I think the team wanted to make
the maps bigger because of the Nomad
this game's version of the Mako but
doing so also spaced out the content
making most of the map feel Barren
that's not to say that the planets don't
have any mystery to them but most if not
all of it is already known to the player
the most unique part about Andromeda is
the introduction of the remnant vaults
but the vaults all look the same minus a
few level design changes so once you've
seen one you've seen them all and while
this next example does eventually get
overplayed a bit its introduction was
nothing short of brilliant there's a
side mission on EOS that has us looking
into the planet's seismic activity it
seems like a routine fetch Quest until
we find the culprit which is this giant
Remnant creature I was blown away when I
first saw this and I still haven't
forgotten that moment now these Remnant
creatures do return on elidin volbe and
the final mission so its reveal isn't as
interesting anymore but that first
interaction was incredible Andromeda has
the chance to capitalize on all this
mystery we're in a completely new Galaxy
so we're unaware where the line actually
stops which means the design team can go
as far as they want with creating as
many strange things as possible like
these tall Remnant beings but 95 of the
planets are nothing special
I will applaud the team though for at
least making the repetitive content
different on each planet go into each
monolith completing a Sudoku puzzle and
then activating the Vault are extremely
tedious on their own imagine having to
do that five different times thankfully
a few of the planets change things up a
bit such as avaro which only has one
monolith instead of three but we have to
climb this hidden sanctuary in order to
do so or hawan kadara before we place an
outpost we have to handle the Rivalry
between Sloane and the infamous
charlatan while still tedious in some
ways I at least appreciated the fact
that I didn't have to do the same thing
over and over again five different times
doing these vaults also gives the player
a sense of genuine progression on EOS
there's a location to the Northeast that
I needed to visit as a part of a side
mission but when I entered the area the
radiation was a level 3 which is
practically lethal at that stage once
the Vault was active though that place
went to level 1 so and I was able to
walk there without being killed this
happens on all the planets that have
some amount of Hazards to them the only
issue is that level 3 is really the only
damaging level levels one and two can
still kill you but takes a long time so
it's only areas that have extremely high
levels of danger where this would be
noticeable which sadly isn't a lot
furthermore I am a bit disappointed that
we're not allowed to pick our outposts
like we did back on EOS all the outposts
on the other planets all come
predetermined kind of ruins the point of
that choice yeah was the first Outpost
but still one Outpost isn't going to
save the initiative we need all of them
and being able to only choose the
function of one of them is strange
besides exploring planets you can also
complete a ton of different missions the
bulk of these are the Loyalty missions
we discussed in the crew section but the
rest are considered helious assignments
or tasks Andromeda does a really good
job at categorizing these as each type
of quest is placed in a specific folder
and quests like the assignments have
subfolders depending on what planet the
mission is located on coming off Mass
Effect 3 this was a godsend and made
completing missions so much easier the
two most important Ally missions besides
the ones relating to our crew are the
ones with the Primus and the Tyrion Arc
these are multi-step quests but
basically the premise is that you find
some Escape pods on Paladin and then
eventually find her way to the Taurean
Arc avatus Ricks was the next in line
for this role but since the current
Pathfinder is now dead he has the chance
to take up that role you can either tell
him he should or let him decide if he
decides on his own though he chooses not
to take up the position whereas the
asari and solarian missions had backup
Pathfinders just in case the current one
died in the terrium one it's either
avatus or no one as for the other
Mission it basically has us teaming up
with the Primus the archon second in
command I mentioned earlier how the
archon was losing support and the Primus
is one of those people she's enjoying
our side nor does she agree with our
ideals but she helps us anyway because
getting the archon out will allow the
cat to focus on their actual goals all
the Primus ends up doing is giving us a
kill code for her ship she says that
eventually she'll be called upon by the
archon to kill us but if her ship is
disabled she won't be able to this is
basically an enemy of my enemy is my
friend kind of relationship because the
archon dying proves beneficial to both
parties the Primus will be the new
leader of the catch and then can bring
the cat back in line to focus on their
original goal and we can stop the archon
from trying to use already in to exalt
our species overall Mass Effect
Andromeda side content isn't too bad I
found the exploration to be fun at first
but it was really starting to become a
drag after spending hours on one planet
just doing tedious tasks I was a big fan
though of some of the choices not being
delegated to the main quest it creates
more depth and also Awards players for
going out of their way to do more
content now once again the actual
outcomes of these choices are small as
we'll soon see but I'm glad that there
was at least choices at All My Hope Is
that this version of the side content
stays in the next Mass Effect game
BioWare really has something gray here
now that we know it's possible to create
that Planetary Exploration we've been
wanting since Mass Effect 1. I think the
core idea of this game's side content is
good if the team irons out some of the
Kinks we might have the perfect version
of this in a sequel now that everything
has been discussed we can now return to
the main quest and we're roughly at the
point of no return since Ryder and the
crew have the coordinates to Meridian we
can now make our way over there the
board of directors though is not happy
with our plan and refuses to help us so
we have to conspire with some of the
other Pathfinders the group decides that
if they use this new tech they just made
called ghost storm it could confuse the
cat's radar sensors allowing them a
chance to land on Meridian before things
get ugly the Pathfinders though won't be
joining us despite the fact that 90 of
this was their own plan likely because
they're violating a direct order by
doing this once we have arrived though
we have to actually activate Meridian to
do this we have to interface with these
two control panels and we discover a lot
of important details firstly is that
Meridian is not the name of this place
Meridian is a completely different
structure this places the command center
that was separated from Meridian the
reason these two objects were separated
was because of the Scourge The Scourge
is then learned to be a man-made
explosion due to something caused by the
Jardin and the Jardin are an ancient
race of beings that created the remnant
the monoliths Meridian and apparently
the angara as there is a random angaran
in a test chamber additional details are
unknown at this time but that is quite a
lot to unpack the Jordan could possibly
be the reason as to why the angara have
very little knowledge of their culture
since they were created by the Jardin
for his specific purpose once again what
that purpose is is also unknown this may
also explain the AI unvold which could
have been created to watch over them I'm
also glad that the scourge got some
mention as its appearance in the story
has definitely been lacking as of late
but once again all we know is that it
was an explosion that created it I have
some thoughts on this info but we'll
have to discuss this in tandem with the
final mission which thankfully is about
to start soon
writer and the crew then have to use
some Scourge data that is found
throughout the system and then return to
the command center in order to find
meridian's actual location once that
info is discovered the archon then
disables Sam as while we were doing this
he was attacking the Hyperion the reason
he is here is because he realizes Sam is
the key to activating the remnant Tech
not because Sam has a different purpose
than intended but as we'll eventually
see if Rudder touches it himself he
starts to feel pain Zayn was able to do
this without hurting him so the archon
is rating the hyperion to take Sarah
since she also has a Sam implant in her
I find it a little odd that the archon
is having no issues with this
considering the Hyperion is attached to
the Nexus at the moment so there should
be an entire fleet of people shooting at
him but anyway since Sam is disabled and
Sam is deeply connected to writer Ryder
collapses we then have to play as Sarah
for a bit and reset Sam to my surprise
once again Sarah actually manages to
live through this in fact she lives long
enough to see the credits which is fine
I definitely didn't think she would but
my question is then why is she barely in
this game I figure the cryo incident was
used as a way to remove the rider you
didn't pick from the game but seeing as
she's a part of the story why was she
absent for 95 percent of it the only
reason that comes to mind is that they
would have had to make twice as many
lines for these characters since they
are technically Main and Side characters
which means even more money would have
to go to voice acting which they may
have not had still if that was the issue
why not just kill her off then once she
succeeds though Scott is revived and can
now walk now that the archon has taken
the ark the team is running out of
options until Ryder finds a control
panel which when activated allows him to
control some remnant forces
I cannot stress enough how stupid this
whole scene is not only is the control
panel just out in the open it's
conveniently right next to where they
landed I have never seen a more obvious
deus ex machina in my whole life it's as
if the writers just practically gave up
at this point but with some of the
remnant on their side the team realizes
that those forces combine with their
allies are enough to fight the archon
this then leads into a large-scale war
it's very similar to the ending of Mass
Effect 3 but unlike that game we
actually get to see our choices ephra
the Moshi sloaner Reyes the Pathfinders
Jaws family vorn Kalinda Drax Scouts and
the AI from vold all show up depending
on our choices this mission is basically
one long combat Arena and at each
section a new person may join the team
now that doesn't mean we're gonna have a
dozen people by the end they just get
swapped out for the next group basically
all these people serve the same purpose
making their current fight easier since
there's more people to help their
inclusion was such an amazing decision
and made the choices feel like they had
actual weight to them now am I happy
that this is the only change these
choices brought to the table absolutely
not but that's to be expected I've tried
to find some info on this but I've come
up with nothing I've been trying to
figure out whether or not Andromeda was
meant to be a Trilogy it's very clear
that the next Mass Effect game will be
in the Milky Way and given andromeda's
mixed reception it seems like a sequel
is out of the question these choices
would have probably had more impact in a
sequel but since there's only one game
at the moment we aren't 100 sure that's
the case it's really hard to claim that
andromeda's choices suck because if
these are considered bad Mass Effect 1
is the worst game in the series think
about it what choices actually had
outcomes Mass Effect 1 had the rachni
Queen the colonists on Pharos Rex's Fate
Ashley vs Kaden the council and the
human Ambassador only Rex and then
Ashley or Kaden were the only ones that
actually had outcomes to them the
council's decision does have an
immediate change but has not until Mass
Effect 3 where that really comes into
play same with the Ambassador and the
rachni queen Mass Effect 1 barely has
any outcomes but the reason this didn't
bother me is because I knew they'd be
touched upon later Mass Effect 1 was
just planting the seed with Andromeda
that's harder to determine even though
those choices didn't have an impact then
most people probably assume that the
choice with the rachni queen would come
back in the future in Andromeda I could
only see the AI the leader of kedara and
maybe the Cardinal be touched upon later
there is also another Choice after the
credits end as well which does fall into
this category but that's all I can think
of I'm sure BioWare could think of some
way to include the Pathfinders Kalinda
vorn and maybe some others but nothing
really sticks out like those do and
that's because Andromeda really suffers
from a lack of intrigue as after Rider
makes it past the combat Arenas he has
to fight the archon once he's defeated
though Meridian is activated the planets
of Helios are now habitable the prime
mistakes of her position as head of the
ket and the credit's role there is very
little Intrigue left in this game
because the game doesn't give us a
reason to be excited about what's next
the dangling plot threads left are the
higher ups of the cat the scourge and
the Jardin
The Scourge despite being important to
the story barely gets any mention and
any time it's put in as a hazard The
Tempest always finds a way around it
making it seem like it's not as deadly
as it's supposed to be the Jardin are
only mentioned by name once and their
claim to fame is the remnant vaults but
to our knowledge all they do is make
planets habitable so what do they want
with the angara their relevance to the
main plot is practically zero and it
seems like BioWare knew this as all the
information regarding the jardan and the
scourge was revealed at the 11th hour
rather than slowly added over the course
of the story the Jordan's Tech is
integral to the plot but the species
themselves isn't whereas in the trilogy
the protheans and their Tech were the
beacon on Eden Prime is close in
comparison to these vaults in terms of
the purpose they serve in the story but
the beacons told us how the protheans
were wiped out the prothean's extinction
was a core part of the story as it was
done by an unknown race fifty thousand
years ago plus species don't just
disappear overnight the vaults tell us
that the jardan are really nice people
that make planets habitable we have no
information on them we don't know why
they made the angara or what the point
of the vaults were other than allowing
them to live on the planets that weren't
habitable from this information it's not
far off to assume that the rest of the
series was just going to be us
colonizing the whole galaxy by using the
remnant Tech and making sure to stop the
cat along the way now there could be
some crazy twist in the next game but we
don't know what that could be Mass
Effect 1 perfectly interweaved its
current plot and overarching plot in a
way that was not only able to expand the
world of the mass effect universe but
also get us excited as to what would
come next we didn't know what was going
to happen in the sequel but we knew the
Reapers were involved somehow with
Andromeda all we know is that the cat
are probably still going to fight us and
that the main goal will likely be
colonizing the Galaxy basically it's the
same plot as this game but now at a
galaxy-wide scale and look I'm a white
American so colonization is deeply
ingrained into my blood but the idea of
doing the same exact thing over again
does not interest me in the slightest
the only things we know of that could
change the story from what it will
eventually become are the Jordan and the
scourge both the Jardin as a species get
zero mention in this game so we have no
clue what their plans are and the
scourge also gets barely mentioned it's
possible that the scourge could become a
new threat as it continually grows
reaching out to certain planets meaning
if we don't stop it it could wipe out
life in the Galaxy but once again it's
still a part of the main idea colonizing
Andromeda that's the core of the issue
having that be the main premise of this
series is not very interesting that's
what we were told in the beginning of
the game that the initiative was started
to colonize Andromeda but upon going
there we ran into two threats The
Scourge and the cat the cat and the
scourge are the antagonistic forces of
the story because they prevent the
protagonist from achieving their goals
living safely on Andromeda the game
gives us no indication that the story is
anything but that and even if there was
plans to do that in a sequel it wasn't
shown here Mass Effect 1 did this by
having the Geth and sarin seemed like
the main threat until we met Sovereign
imagine if we met Sovereign and Mass
Effect 2 that would leave a lot to be
desired because then the plot is just
stopping a rogue Specter for some
unknown reason Andromeda is doing
exactly this however the game still has
one Lifeline that secret we talked about
at the beginning of the video but that
might end up actually being the most
disappointing part of the whole game in
that side mission where we track down
the memories once all of them are found
we discover the real truth Jean Garson
was losing money and losing time she
couldn't get enough support for the
initiative project until a mysterious
benefactor came by and opted to donate
as much money as she needs this
benefactor also convinced Al Grado to
join the initiative likely due to his
advancements in AI the reason this
benefactor funded the project was
because there were some rumors about
something coming to the Milky Way which
could start a full-scale war these were
simply rumors at the time but a
well-respected former N7 member made
those rumors become a reality yes the
reason the initiative was continued was
because the benefactor wanted to make
sure the Milky Way species had a chance
to survive because the Reapers were
coming and I mean
yeah
what else was it gonna be it doesn't
take a rocket scientist to understand
that that was the plan all along I may
not have guessed it right away but my
first thought while playing Andromeda
was wow they sure caught a lucky Break
by escaping right before hit the
fan only to find out that was the whole
point the benefactor could have been
used to expand this plot more but it was
just used as a callback to a previous
game in a way that was so painfully
obvious it wasn't even worth mentioning
that being said it is also learned that
the benefactor did Kill G and Garson and
cover it up earlier in the video I
mentioned how tan was eighth in line for
the director Siege because other people
above him were killed G and Garson the
founder was one of them everyone assumed
she died during the scourge attack that
killed the others but through some
investigation it showed that the
benefactor actually had her killed the
thing is though killing Gian Garson does
what exactly leave a leadership position
open for the benefactor to take cool we
still have to colonize helius it is also
worth mentioning that the benefactor did
know about the Reapers before even
Shepard news so once again there might
be something to salvage here it's just
not a a whole lot had the orders of the
games actually been swapped in Mass
Effect Andromeda was the first in terms
of release order then things could have
actually been way more interesting here
as then Mass Effect 1 would allow us to
play as that N7 Soldier they were
talking about and learn about these
so-called Reapers but since it's the
latest game in the series not only did
we already know about this but the
reapers are finished the war is already
over so this secret reveal is just a
pointless callback disguised as
something deep and mysterious
to close the game and this video were
presented with one final Choice Ryder
gets to choose an ambassador to
represent a galactic Council
sorry wrong game Ryder then gets to
choose an ambassador to represent uh oh
no I was right yeah the game rips off
the same Choice as mass effect 1. in
fact Andromeda is also entering the
realm of plagiarism in these last two
missions as in both games we find the
base that is the answer to all our
questions but can't get there because
the council doesn't agree so we have to
disobey their command and go alone the
team then finds that information which
expands their knowledge of the ancient
race of beings that's been referenced
all game and then in the nick of time
defeat the bad guy right when they're
about to succeed in their plan
the game also reenacts the ilos landing
scene although admittedly that's in the
final mission not the one before it from
that alone it's clear Andromeda really
wanted to capture the beauty of Mass
Effect 1. a game that created one of the
most well-known IPS in gaming history
and it had the opportunity of a lifetime
a whole new Galaxy filled with new lore
species disasters and planets that
haven't been touched upon yet Andromeda
never takes full advantage of this while
its cast of characters were likable and
filled with personality its main quests
lacked both Andromeda wanted to be like
Mass Effect 1 but didn't fully
understand what made the first game what
it is the meeting with Sovereign is
still in my opinion the greatest moment
the series has ever had and its World
building characters and main quest with
a cherry on top of that delicious
dessert Andromeda has the characters but
it's missing that World building and
main quest quality the cat have a
similar form of reproduction to the
Reapers and while I'm all for reusing
old ideas Andromeda just copied the
original work and also somehow made it
worse than the original in the process
the ketter also not developed enough as
their motivation for exultate Nation are
unclear the greediness of wanting to be
better than everyone leading to the
species Gene stagnating is a really good
story beat an exaltation being the way
to solve that problem is also a great
start but this idea is just shown to us
and never developed Andromeda simply
shows us that exultation exists but
doesn't bother to do anything with it
there is no mention of whether or not
the cat are going extinct or if the
higher ups are hoarding all the good
traits that everyone has to fight for
the scraps Andromeda had really backed
itself into a corner as it's unclear
where the story was even going to go in
the next title given the information we
have but it doesn't seem like that would
ever happen anyway due to the mixed
reception of Andromeda it seems like its
story is either going to be on extended
Hiatus or cast off into the MD vacuum of
space as the next game will see us
return to the Milky Way well I'm not too
fond of the idea of killing off this new
series just because of one bad title I
could see why they would Andromeda is
not a good game in fact it's the worst
Mass Effect game in the series but
underneath all its flaws are some
genuinely interesting ideas I've always
been one for Second Chances and if
Andromeda gets a sequel I will gladly
welcome it with open arms as I want this
new series to succeed but I'm not the
one that gets to make these decisions
maybe Andromeda deserves the same fate
as the initiative to be cast out into
dark space never to be seen again or
maybe it deserves a second chance so
that maybe it will find some stable
footing amongst the gaming industry Lord
knows they'll need a Pathfinder to do
that though
thank you all for watching today and I
hope you enjoyed now that we're finally
done with the Mass Effect series it's
time we moved on to something else I
haven't thought about what series our
game to tackle yet if I'm being honest
but I'll likely update you on a
community post soon that being said be
sure to like And subscribe if you're new
and thank you to my returning viewers
for coming back to another video
take care everyone goodbye